tu es belle le prêt de parler trop n'est
pas un gros défaut et tout peut
s'arranger même s'il ya du boulot
mais si tu veux arrêter un peu nous
pourrions jouer à d'autres jeux à
d'autres jeux isabelle c'est belle
isabelle découlent et maintenant que je
te connais je ne pourrai plus jamais
t'oublier
non isabelle tu es belle isabelle
découlent
isabelle tu es belle t'es cool mais tu
me saoules
pour te dire mais modou j'ai un truc un
peu fou j'appelle quand t'es pas là tu
m'interrompt papa mais ton répondeur à
son tour à tous mes mots a coupé court à
poupet cours isabelle isabelle est cool
tu m'as tu irais c'est certain pourtant
j'aurais dû rebrousser chemin oui
isabelle tu es belle isabelle t'es cool
isabelle théberge c'est cool mais tu me
saoules
mes espoirs ou les c'est lorsque tu t'en
vas au maire un tout petit répit pour
une courte nuit
musée l'aftu rêver si fort dans ma tête
j'avais bien d'accord ça résonne encore
isabelle tu te belle zabel s'écoule
auras tu rejoues enfin le désir
d'écouter ce que j'ai à te dire un
isabelle
tu es belle isle save est égaux la
navette est belle c'est cool du tout
sa veine
isabelle s'écoule nous de nous
relaierons pris notre amour éperdu n'y a
jamais cru
isabelle
de belles
isabelle tes collègues
elizabeth ii belge découle mais tim soul
le fait de parler trop n'est pas un gros
défaut et tout peut s'arranger même s'il
ya du boulot mais pour moi que tu sois
julie armelle antoine où ophélie
souvient lilly
mais
ségo
des bêtes est cool mais dessous
au 8e belle audi cool
isabelle teibel t'es cool mais une foule